♪ (upbeat music) ♪
Good morning everyone, I'm Alina,
program manager for TensorFlow.
(applause)
Thank you.
Welcome to the 2019
TensorFlow Developer Summit.
This is our third annual and
largest developer summit to date,
and I'm so happy to have
all of you here
both right here in the room
and on the Livestream.
Welcome.
So I'm just curious
by a show of hands,
who traveled a little bit further,
maybe, to get here?
Europe?
Asia?
Africa?
As far as Australia?
Woo, awesome.
Welcome to all of you.
We have a lot of great talks ahead,
some exciting announcements
and cool demos, so let's get going.
We are living in a formative moment
of history right now,
where machine learning is experiencing
an unprecedented revolution.
The way we fundamentally think about
and interact with computer systems
has inherently changed
due to the breakthroughs
in the field of AI.
and this is due to three major factors.
First, we have lots more compute
specially designed ML accelerator
like these TPUs,
let you train models faster
than ever before.
Secondly, we have breakthroughs
in the field of machine learning.
Their novel algorithms
created every month
like a BERT and an innovative approach
to natural language processing
which lets anyone around the world
train their own state-of-the-art
question-answering system.
And finally, we have lots
and lots of data.
We're seeing new waves of data sets
come from all kinds of disciplines.
For example, the new
open images extended data set.
This is a collection
of over 478,000 images
that volunteers have added
with the pursuit
of inclusivity and diversity.
So, all three of these
are basically changing
how we solve challenging,
real-world problems,
and it's really cool to see
that TensorFlow is the platform
that's powering
this machine learning revolution.
It's allowing developers, businesses
and researchers around the world
to benefit from intelligent applications.
And we've been really amazed
by what the community
has built with TensorFlow.
Developers have been
using TensorFlow to solve problems
in in their local communities.
So I don't know if any of you
were in the Bay Area
during the tragic Paradise fire,
but one of the consequences was
that air quality was really bad.
It was in the high to mid to 200s
on the Air Quality Index.
And as difficult as this was for
us in Delhi, India during winter.
The air quality can get up to about
the 400s on Air Quality Index,
and this is considered very dangerous.
So pollution sensors
can help gauge air quality
but they're very expensive
to deploy at scale.
So a group of students in Delhi
built image classifiers in TensorFlow
and use those to build an app
called Air Cognizer,
and what it does is basically just
by using the images on a smartphone
it gives an accurate
estimation of the air quality.
Businesses are also fundamentally
improving their products and
services built with TensorFlow,
for example, Twitter strives
to keep its global users informed
with relevant and healthy content.
But this can be hard,
when the users follow hundreds
or even thousands of people,
so to solve this, Twitter launched
ranked timeline, an ML power feed
which has the most relevant tweets
at the top of the time timeline,
ensuring users never missed their
best and most relevant content.
And by using TensorFlow's
ecosystem of tools
like TensorFlow Hub, TensorBoard
and TensorFlow Model Analysis,
Twitter was able to reduce
both training and model iteration time
as well as increase the timeline
quality and engagement for users.
Specific industries are also
being very much transformed by ML.
GE Healthcare, for example
is using TensorFlow
to improve MRI imaging.
These TensorFlow models,
they're real-time on MRI scanners
and can actually detect the orientation
of the patient inside the scanner.
And this is really great
because not only does this
help the diagnosis,
but also lowers the errors
and exam time.
But also, what's really cool is
it basically expands this technology
to many many more people around the world.
TensorFlow also powers
bleeding-edge research.
A team of scientists, researchers
and engineers
at nurse Oak Ridge National Laboratory
at VIDYA
recently won the Gordon Bell Prize
for applying deeplearning
to study the effects
of extreme weather patterns
using high-performance computing.
They built and scaled a neural
network using TensorFlow,
of course, to a run on Summit,
the world's fastest supercomputer.
They achieved a peak
and sustained throughput
of 1.13 exaFLOPS and FPC-16
which is equivalent to more than
a quantalian computations per second.
I think I need to pause for a second
because that is ridiculously fast.
Right?
In addition to these awesome examples,
there are thousands and thousands
of people all over the world
doing amazing work using TensorFlow,
and the power and impact
of TensorFlow would not be what it is
without all of you, thank you.
It's with your help and interest
that TensorFlow has become the most
widely adopted ML framework in the world.
And right here, I'd like to
show the latest map of GitHub stars
who self-identified their location.
I'm sure many of the dots
on this map are right here
in the room and on the Livestream,
so I just want to say
thank you one more time.
And this growth
has been absolutely amazing.
TensorFlow has been downloaded
over 41 million times,
and has over 1800 contributors worldwide.
Last November, we celebrated
TensorFlow's third birthday
by taking a look back
at the different components
that we've added throughout the years.
But today, we'd like to talk
about how TensorFlow
has matured as a platform
to become an entire
end-to-end ecosystem.
And TensorFlow 2.0 is
the start of a new era,
and we're committed
and focused on making it
the best ML platform for all our users.
To talk more about TensorFlow 2.0
I'd like to introduce Rajat Monga,
Engineering Director
of TensorFlow on stage.
Thank you.
(applause)
Thank You, Alina.
Hello, everyone, I'm Rajat.
I am an engineer at TensorFlow
and have been involved
with this since the very beginning.
It's been great to see
what we've been up to
over the last few years.
All the amazing growth
and all the amazing things
that you've done with it.
It's also been great to hear from you.
You told us what you like about TensorFlow
and equally importantly,
what you would like to see improved
in TensorFlow.
Your feedback has been loud and clear.
You asked for simpler, more intuitive
APIs in developer experiences.
You pointed out areas
of redundancy and complexity,
and you asked for better
documentation and examples,
and this is exactly what we've been
focusing on with TensorFlow 2.0.
To make it easy, we focused on Keras
for a single set of API's
and combine it with Eager Execution
for the simplicity of Python.
With flexibility to try the craziest ideas
and ability to go beyond an exaFLOP
TensorFlow is more powerful than ever.
With the same robustness
and performance
you expect in production,
battle-tested in Google.
Let's start with the overall
architecture for TensorFlow.
You may be familiar
with this high-level architecture.
There have been lots
of components and features
we've added throughout the years
to help support workloads
to go from training to deployment.
With TensorFlow 2.0,
we're really making sure
that these components
work better together.
Here's how these powerful
API components fit together
for the entire training workflow.
With tf.data for data
ingestion and transformation,
keras and premade estimators
from model building,
training with eager execution and graphs,
and finally packaging
for deployment with SavedModel.
Let's take a look at some examples.
The first thing you need is data.
Often, you may want
to validate results or test your new ideas
in common public data set.
TensorFlow data sets includes
a large and rapidly growing
collection of public data sets
that you can get started with very easily.
And combined with tf.data,
it is simple to wrap your own data too.
Here is a small sample
of the data sets that are available,
and all of these
and many more are included there.
Then with keras,
you can express the model with layers,
just as you are used to thinking about it.
Standard training and evaluation
is packaged as well,
with model.fit and .evaluate.
Since deep learning models
are often computationally expensive,
you may want to try scaling this
across more than one device.
TensorFlow comes pre-built
with MirroredStrategy
that works with small additions
to your code.
Starting from a pre-trained model
or component
also works well to reduce some
of this computational cost.
To make it easy,
TensorFlow Hub provides a large
collection of pre-trained components
that you can include in your model
and even fine tune
for your specific data set.
Keras and .estimator
offers high-level building blocks
for an easy-to-use package.
They come with everything
you might need for typical training jobs.
But, sometimes you
need a bit more control.
For example, when you're
exploring new kinds of algorithms.
Let's say, you wanted to build
a custom encoder for machine translation.
Here's how you might do this
by subclassing a model.
Here, you can focus
on implementing
the computational algorithm,
and let the framework
take care of the rest.
And you could even
customize the training loop
to get full control over the gradients
and the optimization process.
While training models,
whether packaged with keras
or more complex ones,
it's often valuable to
understand the progress,
and even analyze the model in detail.
TensorBoard provides
a lot of visualization to help with this,
and now it comes full integration
with intercollab
and other Jupiter notebooks,
allowing you to see
the same visualizations
right from within your notebook.
All of these features
are available in TensorFlow 2.0,
and I'm really excited to announce
that our alpha release is available
for you as of today.
(applause)
Many of you in the room
and across the world
really helped with lots of work
in testing to make this possible.
I really like to take this moment
to thank you all.
Please give yourself a round of applause.
We really couldn't
have done this without you.
(applause)
In addition to all the great
improvements we talked about,
this release comes
with a Conversion Script
to help you upgrade from 1.X.,
and a compatibility module
to give you access to 1.X. APIs
for easy transition,
and we are working towards the full release
over the next quarter.
There's a lot of work going
on to make TensorFlow 2.0
really work well for you.
You can track the progress
and provide feedback
on the TensorFlow GitHub projects page.
You asked for better documentation
and we worked to streamline our docks
for APIs, guides and tutorials.
All of this material
will be available today
on the newly redesigned
TensorFlow.org website.
Where you'll find more examples,
documentation and tools to get started.
We're really very excited
about these changes and what's to come.
And to tell you more about
improvements in TensorFlow
for research and production.
I'd like to welcome Megan Kacholia
on stage, thank you.
(applause)
Thanks, Rajat.
TensorFlow has always been a platform
for research to production.
We just saw how TensorFlow,
as high-level APIs,
make it easy to get started
and build your models.
Now, let's talk about how it improves
powerful experimentation for researchers,
and let's you take models
from research and prototyping
all the way through to production.
Researchers have been using TensorFlow
for state-of-the-art research.
We can see it in paper publications,
which are shown over the past few years
in this chart.
But powerful experimentation begins
and really needs flexibility.
This begins with Eager Execution
with TensorFlow.
In TensorFlow 2.0 by default, every Python
command is immediately executed.
This means you can write your code
in the style you're used to
without having to use Session.Run.
This also makes a big difference
in the realm of debugging.
As you iterate through with Eager Mode,
you'll eventually want to distribute
your code onto GPUs, TPUs
and other hardware or accelerators.
For this, we've
provided tf.function
which turns your eager code
into a graph, function by function.
You get all of the familiar tools
like Python, control-flow, asserts,
even print
but can convert to a graph
anytime you need to,
including when you're ready
to move your model into production.
And even with this,
you'll continue to get great debugging.
Debug ability is great,
not just in Eager,
but we've made huge improvements
in tf.function and graphs as well.
In this example shown here,
we're splitting a tensor
using tf.function which creates a graph,
but because of the mismatched inputs,
you get an error.
As you can see,
we now give users the information
about the file and the line number
where the error occurred in the model
to help you more quickly
track things down,
so you can continue iterating.
We've made the error messages concise,
easy to understand and actionable.
We hope you enjoy these changes
and they make it much easier for you
to quickly iterate and progress
with your models.
Performance is another area
we know that researchers
as well as all users
for that matter, care about,
and we've continued improving
core performance in TensorFlow.
Since last year,
we've sped up training on eight
NVIDIA Tesla V100 by almost double.
Using a Google Cloud TPU V2,
we've boosted performance by 1.6x.
And with Intel MKL Acceleration
we've got an inference speed up
by almost three times.
Performance will continue to be
a big focus of TensorFlow 2.0
and a core part of our
progress to final release.
TensorFlow also provides
flexibility to enable researchers,
and this is with many add-on libraries
that extend and expand TensorFlow
in new and useful ways.
Some of these add-on libraries
or extensions
to make certain problems easier,
like TF.Text with Unicode
and the new ragged Tensor type.
In other cases, it lets us explore
how we can make machine
learning models fairer and safer
by a TF Privacy.
You'll also hear new announcements
on TF-Agents for reinforcement learning,
and tomorrow, we'll be discussing
the new TF federated library
for federated learning.
Deep learning research is also being
applied to real-world applications
using TensorFlow.
Here are a few examples
from researchers at Google
where we see them applying it
to areas like our data centers.
We're making them more efficient
with AI control system
that delivers energy savings.
Our apps like Google Maps,
the one shown in the middle,
which has a new navigation feature
called global localization.
It combines visual positioning service,
street view, and machine learning
to more accurately identify
position and orientation.
And devices like the Google Pixel
that use machine learning
to improve depth estimation
to create better portrait mode photos
like the one shown here.
In order to make these
real-world applications a reality,
you must be able to take models
from research and prototyping.
all the way through
to launching and production.
This has always been a core strength
and focus for TensorFlow.
Using TensorFlow,
you can deploy your models
on a number of platforms
like shown here.
And models end up in a lot of places,
so we want to make sure
TensorFlow works well
across all of these
on servers and in cloud,
on mobile and other Edge devices,
in browser and JavaScript platforms.
We have products for each of these:
TensorFlow Extended,
TensorFlow Lite and TensorFlow.js
which I'll briefly talk through.
TensorFlow Extended
is our end-to-end platform
for managing every stage
of the machine learning lifecycle.
This spans all the way from ingesting
and transforming your data
to deploying your
machine learning models at scale.
In orange shown here, you can see
the libraries of open-sourced so far.
What this slide alludes to is
that we're now taking a step further
and providing components
built from these libraries
that make up an end-to-end platform.
And note these
are the same components
that are used internally
in thousands of production systems,
powering Google's
most important products.
The components are only part of the story.
2019 is the year
we're putting it all together,
and providing you with an integrated
end-to-end platform.
First, you can bring
your own orchestrator.
Here, we're showing airflow
or kubeflow, even raw kubernetes,
whatever you want.
No matter what orchestrator you choose,
the TensorFlow extending components
integrate with a meta-data store.
This store keeps track of all
the component runs,
the artifacts that went into them
and the artifacts
that were also produced.
This enables advanced features
like experiments, experimentation
and experiment tracking,
model comparison
and things along those lines
that I'm sure you'll be excited about
and will help you
as you iterate through
and work with your production systems.
We have an end-to-end talk coming up
later today from Clemens and his team
in which they'll take you
on a complete tour
of using TensorFlow Extended
to solve a real problem.
Moving on, TensorFlow Lite is
our solution for running models
on mobile and IoT hardware.
it uses a custom streamline file
format and a stripped-down runtime,
so you can deploy TensorFlow
models everywhere your users are.
On-device models can be more
responsive to input than cloud backends,
and they keep user data
on device for privacy
which is very important,
especially in this day and age.
Google and our partners
like IGE in China use TF Lite
for all kinds of tools,
including predictive text generation,
video segmentation
and things like Edge detection.
But under the hood,
TensorFlow Lite is about performance.
You can deploy models
to CPU, GPU and even Edge TPUs,
and expect fast performance,
and we've been refining since we
launched TensorFlow Lite last year.
By using the latest quantization
techniques on CPU,
adding support for OpenGL 3.1
and Metal on GPUs,
and tuning our performance
on Edge TPUs,
we're constantly pushing the limits
of what is possible on device,
and you should can expect even
greater enhancements in the year ahead.
We'll hear details from Raziel
and his colleagues coming up
in a little bit this morning.
Javascript is the number one programming
language in the world
and until recently hasn't
necessarily benefited
from all the machine learning
development and tools.
Last year we released TensorFlow.js,
a library for training
and deploying machine learning models
in the browser and on Node.js.
Since then we've seen huge adoption
in the JavaScript community
with more than 300,000 downloads
and 100 contributors,
but we're just at the beginning
given how big the JavaScript
and web ecosystem is.
Today we're excited to announce
TensorFlow.js version 1.0.
This comes with many
improvements and new features.
We have a library of off-the-shelf models
for common machine learning problems
that run both in the
browser and on node.
We're also adding support
for more platforms
where JavaScript runs
such as electron desktop apps
or mobile native platforms.
and a huge focus in TensorFlow.js 1.0
is on performance improvements.
As an example, compared to last year,
MobileNet inference and
browser is now nine times faster.
You'll learn more about these advances
in our talk later in the day.
Another language that we're
really excited about is swift.
Swift for TensorFlow is reexamining
what it means for
performance and usability.
With a new stack built
on top of TensorFlow's core
and a new programming model
that intends to bring further usability.
And today, we're announcing that Swift
for TensorFlow is now at version 0.2.
It's ready for you to
experiment with, to try out,
and we're really excited to be
bringing this to the community.
In addition to telling you
about version 0.2,
we're also excited to announce
that Jeremy Howard, a fast.ai
is writing a new course
in Swift for TensorFlow.
Chris and Brennan will tell you
a lot more about this later today.
So to recap everything
we've shown you so far.
TensorFlow has
grown to a full ecosystem
from research to production,
from server to mobile
with many languages.
This growth has been
fueled by our community,
and honestly would not
have been possible without the community.
To talk about what we're planning
for you and with you in 2019,
I'll hand it over to Kemal.
(applause)
It's all you.
(Kemal) Thank you, Megan.
Hi, my name is Kemal
and I'm the Product Director
for TensorFlow.
I'm really excited to be here today
for this celebration,
and what we're celebrating
is the most important part
of what we're building,
and that's the community.
Personally, I love building
developer platforms.
I used to be a developer
as an entrepreneur,
and now I get to
enable other developers
by building together a better platform.
When we started working on 2.0,
we turned to the community,
we started with the request
for common process,
consulting with all of you
on important product decisions.
We received valuable feedback
and we couldn't have built 2.0
without you.
And some of you wanted
to get more involved
so we created special
interest groups or sigs
like Networking
or Tensor Board to name a few.
And sigs are really
a great way for the community
to build the pieces of TensorFlow
that they care the most about.
We also wanted to hear more
about what you were building,
so we launched a Powered
By TensorFlow campaign.
And I am going to say we were amazed
by the creativity of the project,
from biological image analysis,
to custom wearables,
to chat BOTS.
So after three years,
our community is really thriving.
There're almost 70
machine learning GDEs right now.
Around the world,
1800 contributors on core alone,
and countless more of you
who are doing amazing work
to help make TensorFlow successful.
So on behalf of the whole TensorFlow team
we want to say a huge thank you.
(applause)
So we have big plans for 2019,
and I would like to make
a few announcements.
First, as our community grows,
we welcome people
who are new to machine learning
and it's really important
to provide them
with the best educational material,
so we're excited to announce
two new online courses.
One is with deeplearning.ai
and it's published
in the Coursera platform.
And the other's with Udacity.
The first batch of these lessons
is available right now,
and they provide an awesome introduction
to TensorFlow for developers.
They require no prior knowledge
to machine learning,
so I highly encourage you
to check them out.
Next, if your students
for the very first time,
you can apply to the
Google Summer of Code program
and get to work
with the TensorFlow engineering team
to help build a part of TensorFlow.
I also talked about the Powered
By TensorFlow campaign.
We're so excited with the creativity
that we decided to launch
a 2.0 hackathon on DevPost
post to let you share
your latest and greatest,
and win cool prizes.
So we're really excited to see
what you're going to build.
Finally, as our ecosystem grows,
we're now having
a second day at the summit,
but we really wanted
to do something more.
We wanted a place where you can share
what you've been building on TensorFlow,
so we're excited to announce
TensorFlow World,
a week-long conference dedicated
to open-source collaboration.
This conference will be co-presented
by O'Reilly Media and TensorFlow,
and will be held
in Santa Clara end of October.
Our vision is to bring together
the awesome TensorFlow World
and give a place for folks
to connect with each other.
So I'd like to invite on stage Gina Blaber
to say a few words about the conference.
(applause)
(Gina) Thank You, Kemal.
O'Reilly is a learning company
with a focus
on technology and business.
We have strong ties
with the open source community
as many of you know,
and we have a history
of bringing big ideas to life.
That's why we're excited
about partnering with TensorFlow
to create this new event
that brings machine learning
and AI to the community.
The event of TensorFlow
happening on October 28 to 31
in Santa Clara.
And when I say community,
I mean everyone.
We want to bring together
the entire TensorFlow community
of individuals and teams,
and enterprises.
This is the place
where you'll meet experts
from around the world,
the team that actually
creates TensorFlow,
and the companies and enterprises
that will help you deploy it.
We have an open CFP right now
on the TensorFlow World site.
I invite you all to check that out
and send in your proposal soon,
so your voice is heard at that event.
We look forward to seeing you
at TensorFlow World in October.
Thank you.
(applause)
Thank you, Gina.
This is going to be great.
Are you guys excited?
Woo!
So we have a few calls to action for you.
Take a course, submit a talk
to TF World, start hacking in 2.0.
By the way, the grand prizes
for a hackathon on DevPost,
will include free tickets
to TensorFlow World.
You know one thing that I love is
to hear about these amazing stories
of people building awesome stuff
on top of TensorFlow.
And as a team, we really
believe that AI advances faster
when people have access to our tools
and can then apply them
to the problems that they care about
in ways that we never really dreamed of.
And when people can really do that,
some special things happen.
And I'd like to share
with you something really special.
(urban noise)
Looking at historical documents
and especially documents
from the Middle Age period,
requires a lot of time
and also a lot of patience.
♪ (gentle music) ♪
In the Vatican Archives,
there are 85km of documents
more or less the length
of the Panama Canal.
The scriptures written
in the medieval handwriting
are different from the ones
we know nowadays.
If one day someone ask me
to transcribe and translate
all the documents
of the Vatican Archive,
I would tell them
that they are completely crazy.
(woman) Looking at this book page by page
and trying to decipher,
read and transcribe whatever is there
takes an enormous amount of time.
It would require an army
of paleographer.
♪ (upbeat music) ♪
(woman 2) What I am excited
the most about machine learning is
that it enabled us to solve problems
that up to 10, 15 years ago
we thought unsolvable.
(Paolo) "In Codice Ratio" was born
from this idea of building a software
that can read and interpret
what is inside those manuscripts.
When we started discussing the problem,
we realized that a solution
based on neural networks
was absolutely necessary.
The choice of TensorFlow
was a natural one.
(Elena) Before using any kind
of machine learning module,
we needed to collect data first.
You have thousands of images
of dogs and cats on the Internet,
but there's very little images
of ancient manuscripts.
We build our own custom
web application for crowd sourcing
and we involved high school students
to collect the data.
I didn't know much
about machine learning in general,
but I found it very easy
to create a TensorFlow environment.
When we were trying to figure out
which model worked best for us,
Keras was the best solution.
The production model runs on
TensorFlow layers and estimator interface.
We experimented
with binary classification
with fully connected networks,
and finally we move
to convolutional neural network
and multi-class classification.
In a short time, we were able to develop
and test the first solutions.
When it comes to recognizing
single characters,
we can get 95% average accuracy.
(Marco) Being able to access an IT tool
greatly shortens the timing.
Being able to solve certain abbreviations
and to understand a text
in that cryptic writing
is something exceptional.
(Serena) This will have an enormous
impact in a short period of time.
We will have a massive quantity
of historical information available.
I just think solving problems is fun.
It's a game against myself,
and how good I can do.
(Marco) The study of history
is extremely important
to understand our present
and to get a perspective on the future.
(applause)
This is such a great story.
I think about the scholars
who wrote these manuscripts.
They couldn't have been
imagined that centuries later,
people will be using computers
to bring back to life their work.
So we're really lucky
to have Elena with us today.
Elena, would you stand?
(applause)
Don't miss the talk
where she will share her story today.
I really hope you have a great day.
We have some really awesome things.
The team and I will be around.
Please come and say hi,
we want to hear from you,
and with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Martin
who will talk about TensorFlow 2.0.
Thank you.
♪ (upbeat music) ♪